[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Thank
you for joining us today.
I am also a UW alum, so
I'm excited to be back
in that territory.
DAVID LEVIN: So when I first
saw this book, "Creating
Compassionate Kids,
Essential Conversations,"
my impression was that
it's a book for parents
with young children.
Is that the audience?
What's your intended
audience for the book?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: So my intended
audience is, like you said,
parents.
But I define parents
very broadly.
There are a lot of people who
are serving a parenting role
in the lives of young children.
We have parents who
are biological parents,
foster parents, step-parents,
grandparents, aunts and uncles.
Sometimes its neighbors,
community members,
early childhood teachers
or other caregivers,
really anybody with young
children in their lives.
DAVID LEVIN: And there's some
emphasis on young children
and kids, but what about
teenagers and older kids?
Does it apply to them at all?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: I think that a
lot of the foundation of what
we do with our young
children forms the foundation
for those relationships
that we have with older kids
and with teens.
And so often, the same
things that we struggle
with our younger
children-- how do we
have conversations
about tough topics?
How do we help them manage
their tough emotions?
This is something that doesn't
go away as children get older.
So there are some things
in the book that are very
specific to young children--
I make storybook recommendations
for how to talk about some
of these topics--
that really are targeted
for those picture
books and those younger ages.
But a lot of the messages
lay that foundation
that should be true
throughout childhood
and into the teen years.
DAVID LEVIN: One other broad
question about the book.
Now there have been a
lot of parenting books.
And some of them give
perhaps questionable
advice that sometimes doesn't
seem so good in retrospect.
How do we know we can
trust your book here?
[LAUGHTER]
SHAUNA TOMINEY: That's
a great question,
and an important question
to ask, especially
because we know how easy
it is to get information.
And how many of you are parents?
Can I ask?
OK, so the vast
majority in the room.
And whether you're a parent
now or plan to be a parent,
or have a young
child in your life
or an older child in
your life in another way,
we are inundated
with information
on what it means to be a parent,
what parenting looks like, what
parenting should look like.
And sometimes that information
is very, very conflicting.
I teach a parenting class
at Oregon State University.
And one of the
activities we do is
we pick topics like
immunizations or some
of these other
challenging topics
that might have conflicting
viewpoints represented
on the internet or
in other sources,
and look at where do you
find that information.
And what you find is that
you'll find information
on all sides of an argument.
And so that's a great question
to ask about a parenting book.
Because the same is true.
There are a lot of
parenting books out.
And many of them offer
potentially conflicting advice
or sometimes advice that's not
really grounded in research.
So one of the
beliefs that I have
is that you should be very
transparent about where
your information comes from.
And so I try to be really
open in the book itself
about both my personal
experiences, which are
blended into what I talk about.
I've been an early
childhood educator.
I've been a parenting educator,
and trained in those best
practices for how
we teach children
about emotions, how
we teach them to talk
about these tough topics.
And quite frankly,
there's a lot that we
know in child development
about how children grow,
develop, and thrive.
But as parents, it's not so easy
to take that information that's
in the textbooks
that are available
and actually turn that
into parenting practices
and deal with the
challenges that we
might have every day
with our young children.
And so in coming to this,
having been in the field,
having heard thousands
of conversations
with children and parents
around the country,
and seen what parents
really struggle with,
what I've tried to do is take
the research we know about--
OK, what is it that
helps children thrive--
and put it into
practice, but also
blend that with those
personal stories.
So I try to be as
clear as possible
of where that's happening so
that the reader has a chance
to take that
information in yourself.
Now in this book, we
go through and talk
about different examples of
challenging conversations
to have with young children.
And I'll never say
there's one right way
to talk about this topic.
Here are some examples.
Here's what we know in research.
And let's add this to
your parenting toolbox
so you can make a choice.
DAVID LEVIN: And I really like
how after the conversations,
you go through and
you go, these are
the key things that we're trying
to do in this conversation.
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Yeah.
DAVID LEVIN: So you can
take away that and kind of
adapt the conversation
to your style somewhat.
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Absolutely.
DAVID LEVIN: And I think you did
a great job of explaining it.
And I know in the about
section about you,
it says that you blend practical
experience with research
to develop and
test programs aimed
at promoting social emotional
skills for children and adults.
And I felt like that
kind of captured
a little bit of what you were
doing in the book, where you
kind of talk about some
of the practical side,
and you mentioned the references
to various bits of research
throughout.
One of the first things you
cover in the book was you
said there's the most
important conversation
you can have with your child.
What is that?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Well, one of
the most important conversations
you can really have is about
loving and accepting your child
for who they are.
That's absolutely foundational
to building trust,
to let your child know that
you're not always going
to love everything they do.
You're not always going
to be behind every choice
that they make.
But you'll always be there
for them as a person.
And that's moving
toward that acceptance
of who they are without shaming
them for being that person.
So really looking at how do we
love and accept our children
for who they are, and help
them understand not only
who they are now, but
who they will grow into
and who they will
become as we also
then help guide them through
some of these challenges.
Because we don't always
like what our children do.
We don't always like or support
the decisions they make.
But that doesn't mean
that we won't be there
for them to come back to us, and
feel like they have that trust
to know that we'll be
there, no matter what.
DAVID LEVIN: Yeah.
And I hear you mentioning
trust a lot right now.
And I feel like that's
a theme that you hit on
throughout the book.
Why is that so important,
the trust with your child
and so on?
SHAUNA TOMINEY:
Well, as I mentioned,
having that trust is so
foundational to relationships
in early childhood and beyond.
When children feel
like they can trust
the parents and the
caregivers in their lives
to be there for them, they're
more likely to turn to them
when challenges come up.
They want to be like them.
They want to learn from them.
It's easier to teach and
guide them along the way.
We also know that when
children experience stress--
which we all do.
We all experience stress.
And so often as
a parent, we want
to shield our child from stress.
We want to keep them
kids as long as possible.
And we want to help them
avoid stressful situations.
But the reality is they're
going to experience stress.
And they're going to
experience challenges.
And knowing that we will be
there to help them through that
can have serious implications.
We're seeing in
research that children
who have trusting relationships
with adults in their lives
who can help them through
stress can actually
minimize the impact of
that stress long term.
DAVID LEVIN: And how
do the conversations
that we have with our kids
help to build that trust?
What types of things
do we do, or even
not do or maybe undermine it?
You can touch on both.
SHAUNA TOMINEY:
Yeah, absolutely.
I think one of the
biggest things we hear
is that children--
as I mentioned, as
parents, we often
want to protect our
children from stress.
And we want to protect
them from things
that we're worried
they're not ready for yet.
There's so much out
there in the world
that our children
are going to face.
There are so many
things that they
might see, that
they might overhear,
that they might become
exposed to on the internet,
at school, on the
news, whether or not
we want them to
be exposed to it,
that oftentimes, when our
very young children come
to us with these
questions of things
that they're seeing or
hearing, we turn to them
and say, well, let's talk
about that when you're older.
Or let's wait and talk
about that another time.
And what we mean is,
I want to protect you.
I want you to be a child
as long as possible.
I don't want you to have
to worry about that now.
What our children
might hear is, I can't
come to you to talk about this.
And that's something that
we really want to avoid,
is not giving our
child that message
without meaning
to that we're not
going to be the ones
who are there to answer
those questions for them.
DAVID LEVIN: Yeah, and
I think related to that,
you have a whole
chapter in here devoted
to heavy topics like death
and divorce and so on.
And yet those related for
kids and young children.
Is this something that we can
wait to talk to them about?
I think you were talking
about some already.
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Yeah.
You know what?
It really depends on our
child, the age of our child,
who our child is, and
what we experience.
So often we talk to our
child about what we know.
We talk to them about what it
is we are experiencing, what it
is we know that they're seeing.
And if you don't mind me
stepping back a moment,
just in setting this up--
when I have had the
opportunity to really
live in different
places in the country
and to hear the different
kinds of conversations
that children and adults
have in different settings.
And one of the
things that I've seen
is that most parents talk
to children about how much
they love them, their hopes
and their dreams for them,
what they want for them.
But there are also
a lot of differences
in the kinds of conversations
that parents and children have,
and that varies by context.
And there are some
children who never
grow up talking
about death, or never
grow up talking about stress.
But on the flip side, there
are other families who
talk about that all the time.
So when I was working
with military families,
for example, those
families were talking
about the stress
of being deployed
or separated from a loved one
from for a long period of time,
and the possible death
or the reality of having
a death in the
family as a result.
When I was working in
inner city urban areas,
there were families there who
talked every day about how
the impact of the color
of their child's skin
would affect how they
were being looked at,
the opportunities that
they had, or the reason
that people would
cross the street
to avoid standing next to them.
And yet these were the
kinds of conversations
that other families
weren't having.
And often, when I think
about this, and whether
or not we should tackle some of
these tough conversations, what
I'm reminded of is that
some of these topics
define a young child's
life every single day.
There are parents who
don't have a choice, who
have to tackle
these tough topics
because they define
their child's life,
how their child is looked
at, the opportunities
that their child has.
And it was having
that experience
to see all of these
different experiences
that children and families had
that really got me thinking
about this book, and to
think about, how do I
as a parent use this opportunity
that I've had to see and peer
into the lives of all of
these children and families,
and to think about for my own
child and then the children
that I work with, how do we
help them be more compassionate?
How do we help them
get those skills
to prepare for what they
might face in their lives,
but also to be more
understanding of what
other children might be
experiencing around our country
and around the world?
And so in a
not-so-small nutshell,
that's one of my
arguments for why we
should talk about these topics.
When our children
want to learn from us,
this is a chance to help
them learn about the world,
about others' experiences, to
be more compassionate to that,
but then also to talk about
skills that they might need
when they face those
challenges, or if they face
those challenges in the future.
DAVID LEVIN: So given--
let's say we buy this, that we
should have that conversation--
what are some strategies
that we can use to have
these types of conversations?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Sure.
So in the book, I
break down the sections
into different types
of conversations.
And one set of conversations
is really about emotions,
and how we help children
manage those tough emotions.
And I think that each of these--
as I'll just briefly touch
on-- these different sections
and types of conversations we
have have different strategies
that go along with them.
And so one of the starting
sections that I talk about
in the book is how we
set up that relationship
with our children,
really listening to them
and giving them a chance to
share, giving them a chance
to listen, and
that back and forth
that goes on between
parents or other adults
and the children in their lives.
In that first section,
where we talk about some
of these strategies
for how do we
do this when our children have
those really tough emotions?
That's one of the
questions that I
think I'm asked most
often about parents,
is how do we talk to children
about those really hard
challenging emotions?
And it's such a big challenge
for a lot of different reasons.
So if you think about--
I'm going to turn things
on you for just a moment.
Those of you who have children--
most folks in the room--
what are the skills
that a new baby
has to communicate or
to have a conversation?
How do they let us know
when they need something?
AUDIENCE: Crying.
SHAUNA TOMINEY: OK, just
heard the universal word, cry.
What else?
What else do they do?
AUDIENCE: They'll fidget.
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Fidget?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Just move around.
SHAUNA TOMINEY:
Yeah, move your body?
Yeah, move around.
Tense, get tense, kick, scream.
We hope sometimes smile.
[LAUGHTER]
Laugh at some point.
We hope for those moments too.
But when our children
are born, they
are essentially programmed
to be a ball of impulses
and instincts, to use their
bodies and their cries
to let us know that
they need something.
Now when we're talking about
how do we have conversations
with young children who
are kicking and screaming
and they can't
talk back with us,
when they get a little bit
older and all they want to do
is run around with a
diaper on their head,
we have to get really creative.
First, we can let
them know that we're
recognizing those
emotions as the way
that they're
expressing themselves.
And as parents,
oftentimes it's our goal
to help children move from
being that child who's
kicking and screaming and
tensing and sometimes smiling,
to being able to say, I'm
angry, or I'm frustrated,
or I'm kind of grumpy,
can you help me calm down?
How many of you know
adults who can do that?
[LAUGHTER]
Maybe not as many as we'd like.
And so in recognizing that
our children's emotions
are actually--
the way that they
express them are
a way of communicating a need,
and then talking about that,
labeling it, being able
to use words ourselves,
and to be a role
model in the way
that we talk about our
own emotions to help them
learn to do that.
And in showing our
children they can
trust us to talk
about their emotions
really in a teaching
kind of way,
rather than a punishing
way, we can also
help set the stage for
these other conversations.
So for thinking about
how we go about tackling
these more complex topics
as our children are ready.
DAVID LEVIN: So you mentioned
emotions and handling them,
and some adults have
trouble with that.
So what are we do when
we're even having trouble
with managing our emotions?
How can we teach the
skills to our kids?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: That's
a great question.
Because as adults,
this isn't something
that we're always
taught ourselves either,
in terms of OK, when we
get really frustrated, that
impulse of that kicking
and that screaming toddler
still lives within us sometimes.
And to really be able
to step back and say,
I'm frustrated, I'm
angry, what's going on--
this is a great chance to
practice thinking about, OK,
what is it I want
my child to do when
they're having this feeling?
And what's our family emotion
rule for frustration or anger
or stress?
Our children have
these feelings.
How can we teach them to
show it in a way that's
effective and appropriate?
And then coming
back to ourselves--
to think about well,
let's talk about this.
What does this look like?
And now I should be practicing
this too as a parent.
So if this is our
family emotion rule--
if our rule is that we're going
to try our hardest to not kick
and throw and scream, but
to stop and say, I'm angry,
I've got to try that too.
And when I don't,
then think about--
all right, when my child
can't do this either,
what do I want them to do?
To step back and say, I
should have done something
differently.
And our child will never
do that, or a teenager--
imagine them coming in
and saying, you know,
last night when you wouldn't
let me take the car out,
and I got so mad and I
just started yelling--
Dad, I shouldn't have done that.
Next time, I'm going
to take a deep breath
and I'm going to come to you
and tell you how I'm feeling.
Can you imagine a
teenager doing that?
[LAUGHTER]
They won't unless we do that
and model it for them first.
It's going to take a lot
of work, but it's worth it.
DAVID LEVIN: So I'm going
to keep asking questions.
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Sure.
DAVID LEVIN: But I
also want to invite--
if any of you have questions
about conversations
with your kids, feel
free to come to the mic
and we'll start to mix those in.
And if not, we'll just
keep going up here.
You can listen to the
two of us talking.
So when I read this--
I read it pretty much
straight through,
given the timing and all.
And I almost felt overwhelmed
by the amount of information
here, and trying to
think about it all.
How would you recommend
that people can kind of
absorb it and apply it best?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: That's
a great question.
There's a lot of
information in this book.
And it's divided
up, as I mentioned,
into different sections
that tackle different kinds
of conversations.
So one section is on those
foundational conversations
about letting our children
know that they can trust us,
that we love them,
that we're going
to manage their emotions in a
way that's teaching and guiding
rather than punitive.
Another section on
self-awareness and acceptance,
and really helping children
learn about the qualities
that will make them who
they are, to those qualities
that make others who they are.
And those conversations
include topics
like sex, gender, gender
identity, race, culture,
different types of families.
And then moving into another
section on conversations
that focus on tough
topics, like you mentioned,
Dave, divorce, death,
suicide, guns, stress, sex,
some of these
challenging topics that
come up over time, and
sometimes earlier than we
expect with our children.
And then the final section
is on these conversations
that help us think about all
that we've been learning,
and applying that to
friendships, to relationships
inside and outside
of the family,
to recognizing privilege,
to really thinking
about how do we find our
voice and make a difference?
And along with that come very
specific and concrete ideas,
so storybook recommendations
with discussion questions,
family activities,
parenting Q & A's.
With all of that being
packed into one book,
I really encourage folks to pick
it up and take a look at what's
helpful at different times.
It's the kind of book that
you can read straight through.
But it may be hard to go through
and really think about, now
how do I apply this at home
if you're not taking it little
by little.
So it's the kind of
book that's meant
to be taken in snippets
if it's helpful.
DAVID LEVIN: Yeah,
really, I guess I
like two things about that.
One, I like the index in back.
So if you're having some
struggle with some topic
or whatever, you can look back
there and see if it's covered.
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Absolutely.
DAVID LEVIN: And two,
like you mentioned,
at the end of the
chapters, there's
the book recommendations.
How do those tie in
and help with you
understanding or working
through the topics better?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: So
storybooks are a great way
to tackle topics that
we might not otherwise
feel prepared to talk
about with our children.
It can be a great
way to also take
a look at challenges like
challenging emotions, anger
or frustration, outside of those
emotionally charged moments.
If our children are in the
middle of a tantrum, that's
not always the best
time to say, oh,
I can see you're
really frustrated.
Let's talk about what
you should do instead.
They're going to
keep on tantruming
and kicking and screaming.
They are emotionally charged.
They are in that fight,
flight, or freeze mode--
not so much freeze,
more of that fight mode.
And they're not listening.
They're not learning.
But we can use books to pull out
of that situation and say, OK--
oh, look what made this
character field really angry
or frustrated or disappointed.
Have you ever felt that way?
What do we do when
we feel that way?
So that's one way.
Another way that I think books
and storybooks are so important
is it's a way to build
empathy, to learn
about others' experiences, to
be able to bring in role models
to your child's life of
people who look like they do,
who think like they
do, dress like they do,
have a family that
looks like theirs.
And that's harder
to do for children
who come from a
non-dominant culture,
or who have a
non-dominant family type.
We have to really
work hard to make sure
our children have role
models who look like they do,
so that they feel
valued, so that they
feel like part of a community.
And I think the
last thing I'll say
about that is I think it's
important for children who come
from dominant groups
and dominant cultures
also to have those role models
from minority and non-dominant
groups so that those children
see one another as part
of that same community too.
So I've tried really
hard in this book
to come up with a wide range
of storybook recommendations
that really depict
children and families
in different
situations, experiencing
different challenges
and strengths,
so that we can have those
role models for our children.
DAVID LEVIN: Sounds great.
I think we have a question.
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So my
question is around kind
of like the age range.
I'm sure the skill
system and methods
that you talk about in
your book apply to children
throughout their lives.
But would you say that
there is a cutoff,
or an age range where these
conversations become really
crucial or have a lasting
impact on kind of, I guess,
how compassionate
children become?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: That's
a great question.
I think that just to tackle age
range, the book, I would say,
is ideal in the 0 to
8 or 9 age range is
where I'd put it in terms
of where the conversation
examples are coming
from, as well as
where the storybooks
are the best fit.
But I think it's
also never too late.
It's never too late
to have a conversation
or to build a relationship
with your child
where you can help them
practice these skills.
We've got to look at
compassion like a scale
or a set of skills,
just like anything else,
just like emotion regulation,
just like anything
that we're learning
and practicing.
And it may be harder
later on if children
haven't had a lot of practice.
But again, it's never too late.
I once had a parent sitting in
a workshop with me who said,
so I've got teenage
boys at home,
and the stuff you're
talking about emotions
and how we talk about it,
I want to do that now.
So what do I do?
Do I just go home and say,
this is how we roll now,
and we're just going to talk
about emotions from now on?
And it was a real question
that he was asking.
Because he hadn't been
doing this at home.
And he said, well, what do I do
if I now see the value in this
and I just want
to change things?
And a big part of that
is putting yourself
up as a role model.
And so coming home and opening
yourself up and saying,
OK, I had a tough
day at work today,
and I kind of want
to talk about this.
Did anyone else have these
kinds of feelings too?
What do you think I
should do about this?
So I hope that
answers your question.
DAVID LEVIN: And we'll
go to their question.
But I think one thing
that I got out of it
is that it's really
good that you start
from a very young age, even
before your children are
non-verbal and so on, to start
to have these conversations.
And I think you're
emphasizing that,
that that's where the
trust comes from and so
on, just continuing throughout.
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Absolutely.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
What are your thoughts about
a conversation with children
about their relationship
with technology,
so that they are in
control and use tech
as their tools to
achieve their goals?
Because otherwise,
a parent that stands
in the way between
a child and a screen
can cause strong
emotions in a child.
I think that's a sight
that can be often found.
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Yeah.
That's a great question.
I think technology is such
a big part of our lives,
and such a big part of
our children's lives,
and even more so for them now
than it was for us growing up.
And society is continuing
to move in that direction.
And I touch a little
bit on technology.
I don't have it as a
specific topic in the book.
I mention it a little
bit here and there.
But I think that like
with anything else,
we have to be a role
model, in looking
at how do we be a good
citizen in using technology?
What are all of the
strengths that technology
brings to our lives?
What are the capacities
that it brings?
What are all of those
tools that can really
enhance what we're doing, our
effectiveness, our efficiency?
But then also looking at what
are some of the challenges?
So some of the ways that
technology is coming out
as problematic is
in cyberbullying,
or in some of the
ways that children
are relating to
each other outside
of those personal moments.
Sometimes we interact with one
another in a different way when
it comes out over technology.
And I really try to think
about it in my own life
too as a parent, modeling what
we want to see in our children.
So thinking about, if
we want our children
to set limits around
the time or the way
that they're using technology,
we have to model that too.
We have to talk about it, share
those family values around it.
What are our rules with that?
And then also
thinking about how do
we engage our children in
that technology in a really
healthy way?
So one of the things that, for
me, as a parent, for example--
and I know many of you
as parents probably
think about this too--
when it's the first day of
school, what do I want to do?
Take a picture and put
it up on social media.
My daughter has not wanted
me to take a picture
and put it on social media
for the last three years.
So since she was
in kindergarten,
I have not posted a first
day of school picture,
as much as I've wanted to.
And that's hard as a parent.
Because I think, well,
this is my life too.
But it's also hers, to
decide how she's shown,
and how she's depicted.
And that I've seen as just
one little lesson in terms
of saying, OK, you've
got to remember,
I will always do this for you.
If you don't want to be
shown on social media,
I won't put your
picture there, just
like how you should treat other
people in the way that you
talk to people, or talk about
people, or whether or not you
post a picture, or
take something down
when you're asked.
We have to learn how to
treat people respectfully
across these platforms,
while also valuing
all of the amazing capacity
that technology brings.
Yeah, thank you.
DAVID LEVIN: I think you've
touched on it a little bit
there, but in a
part of your book,
you talk about I
think respecting
the boundaries of
kids too, when they're
talking about things like,
oh, go give that uncle a hug
or whatever, and they're
like, I don't want to,
and how do you deal with
this type of situation?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Sure.
Well, and I think it does
relate to technology,
and it relates to a lot of areas
what you're talking about too
is in relation to
your body and who
has control over what you do.
And as we are raising our
children-- one of the reasons
that I think having these
kinds of conversations
is so important, and tackling
tough conversation topics
is so important, is
it gives us a chance
to help our children build
skills to think about
what do you want and
what do you not want,
and how do you speak up when
you need something or don't want
something?
But then also showing them
that we will follow through
with that.
For a child to say, I don't
want to hug that person--
it's pretty common to say, no,
go and hug your grandparents,
or go hug your uncle,
or go hug your aunt.
But then we're telling
our child that they don't
have control over their body.
And if we really want them
to believe that they do,
we've got to listen to that too.
And I think part of having
those tough conversations
into other topics as well is
learning that over time, we
have to give more and
more trust to our child
in terms of them
being able to make
those decisions for themselves,
and them having the skills
that they need to
manage conversations
or tough situations
that will come up.
Because we won't
always be there.
DAVID LEVIN: But it is there
a possibility of giving them
too much choice
and too much mand--
I don't know-- kind of like
let them rule the whole thing?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
I think boundaries are
also very important.
We can't say to a
child, I'll listen
to what you need in
terms of technology,
and they say, OK, well,
I'd like to watch shows
for five hours on this
device or that device.
We also set boundaries.
And I think as parents, we also
need to communicate our family
values, whether
it is technology,
or whose choices it is related
to your own body or anything
else.
One of the things-- just to
give an example in the book--
in talking about sex, which is
a challenging topic for many
families--
there's been some research
showing that teens actually
wish that their parents
talked more to them
about family values
around sex, where they're
getting a lot of talks
around safe sex practices,
but not necessarily about
those family values.
That's not always the case.
But that has to be
a piece of this too.
DAVID LEVIN: We have
another question.
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My wife and I come from
a different country,
and we have different
experiences growing up.
Our kids grow up here.
They have a much more
comfortable lifestyle,
I feel like, in general,
at least I think so.
So one of the difficult
conversation topics
usually arise when there
is a sense of entitlement.
At least my wife and I feel
like, when we were growing up,
we didn't have this or that.
And you kind of talked about
it earlier about storybooks.
Do you have any other techniques
to kind of show them, hey, you
know what?
Maybe try to get a better
perspective on their situation,
as far as you growing up here
versus where we grew up from.
Do you have any other tools
aside from like storybooks,
any other techniques?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Yeah.
Well, one, that you
were talking about too
is sharing your
personal stories,
sharing what it was
like growing up.
My mom is an immigrant.
She's from Taiwan.
AUDIENCE: It that
tends to be like,
oh, she keeps saying that again,
that again, that story again?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: But also to say
this is really important for me
to share with you.
Because this is what it was
like when I was growing up.
This is what it's like here.
And I think that even in passing
through the day-- at holiday
time, sometimes when it seems
like there's so much and so
much more than maybe
others are experiencing,
to be able to talk about
that, that we are very
fortunate here, and pointing
out those things that we're
really grateful for, talking
about gratitude, what it is
we're thankful for.
Because others don't
always have these things.
And these are
things in our lives
that we really appreciate.
But it's hard
sometimes when you're
fighting against the
excitement of new things,
or having more
with young children
to have those conversations.
But I it's important
to continually,
in a way that both allows them
to be kids and celebrate what
they want to celebrate,
have that continual reminder
of this is something we
should be thankful for.
Writing thank you notes,
talking about gratitude,
why we're grateful for things.
And also-- I'll go back to
that example of storybooks--
but I think it is
important to show
what other children
experience, and how that's
similar to and different
from your own lives,
to build that empathy and
that understanding as well.
Yeah, thank you.
DAVID LEVIN: So you
talked a little bit
in these various things about
being an example and all.
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Yeah.
DAVID LEVIN: And so if we want
to teach our kids compassion,
is just being nice to other
people just good enough?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: It's a start.
It's a good start.
And it's amazing to see how much
or how little children pick up
on.
One of the examples I
used in the book, just
a simple example,
was holding the door
open for somebody else.
If you hold the door open for
somebody else and your child's
standing there right next
to you, so you think,
they are seeing me stand here
and being a good role model.
Your child may be thinking,
why are you taking so long?
I want to get home, or
I want to go to school,
if you don't talk about it.
And so speaking those words and
what's going on in your head
out loud in terms of holding
the door open, and saying,
you know, I'm going
to hold the door open,
because I see this
person coming who's
holding a lot of
bags in their arms,
and it looks really heavy.
So I'm going to
hold the door open,
because I'd like to
be helpful for them.
And I think that what they're
doing looks really hard.
You start speaking that
inside voice out loud.
It's something that makes
other adults crazy in terms
of, oh, let me move
the chair for you,
because I see that you
are coming back this way,
and you weren't quite far
enough, and so I wanted to--
it makes other adults crazy.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's really good for
kids to hear that language.
And the same thing goes
for the previous question
that we just had in
terms of saying out loud.
I think I'm only
going to do this,
or I'm only going
to take this much,
or I'm not going to buy
anything new because I
feel like we have enough.
Expressing those words
out loud not only
helps children see those
examples of compassion
a little bit more, but it
teaches them how to think.
It teaches them how to stop
and think about somebody else's
feelings first, yeah.
DAVID LEVIN: I think we
have another question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I have teenage girls at
home, and still two years apart.
And outside, they're nice,
they're the best girls.
And out with my family,
it's always perfect.
But at home--
[LAUGHTER]
--between each other, it's
a very different story.
And I'm not going to
repeat some of the things
that they call each other.
[LAUGHTER]
And I make sure that
they understand,
OK, this is what
happened at home,
and I'm going to say don't
say that to your sister,
it's not appropriate.
And they also
acknowledge that no, they
are not using these words
or these behaviors outside.
They understand that.
My hope is that it's
going to continue.
It's going to be true at home
and true outside as well.
Any recommendation on how
to deal with this situation?
SHAUNA TOMINEY:
Well, one, I think
celebrating what's
happening outside the home,
in terms of
everyone's doing well,
and by all appearances
outside, folks are like,
oh, they've got it all together.
And I think that happens
so often in families
too, especially
with young children.
Has anyone had that
experience where home just
feels like it's falling apart
and a mess, and then folks say,
your child is so sweet, and
doing so well, and so kind,
and you think, really?
Thank goodness!
[LAUGHTER]
And some of that
is that it's hard.
It's a lot of work to
really manage your emotions,
to manage your behaviors.
To keep a check on what
you're saying all the time
is hard to do.
It takes a lot of energy.
It takes a lot of intensity.
It takes a lot of
brainpower for our children.
And so knowing that
by the time they
come home that
they're exhausted.
They may be just done.
The fact is they can do it.
And you're seeing it
happen outside of the home,
so you know it's there.
So one, celebrate that.
So that's great.
And two recognize that, yeah,
I think that that's probably
true across many families,
that we don't always
treat each other within our
families as compassionately
as we treat people
outside of our families.
And that hopefully,
that'll grow and change
as you continue to have those
conversations about what we do,
what we don't do, what
we value as a family.
And opening up some of
those conversations about,
how was your day?
What are you thinking about now?
Helping them connect when
they can in different ways.
That wasn't a really
specific answer,
but I'd be happy to
talk more afterward too.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Thank you.
DAVID LEVIN: I
know in my family,
I have two kids that I'm--
anyway, I can relate.
[LAUGHTER]
But I [INAUDIBLE] reading
something your book,
and you were talking
about how you
had a situation
with two kids that
were kind of arguing and so on.
And I know my tendency at
times has been to kind of jump
in and solve things.
So I jump right in
and kind of like--
but I think in your book,
you had a different type
of scenario going.
Can you tell us more about that?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Sure.
I think there has to be
a blend and a balance.
And just like with
anything else,
we want to make sure
our children have
the skills they need to
navigate different situations.
And so in navigating
sibling rivalry,
do we jump in right
away and say, OK, I
told you not to do that.
You go to your room,
you go to your room,
let's just break it up.
Versus helping them figure
out how to problem solve,
and how to come together
and say, wait a minute,
what happened?
Let's talk through this.
And when children are younger,
being there to guide them
through what happened.
Why don't you tell
me what happened?
How are you feeling about this?
How are they feeling about this?
To really get children to focus
on one another's feelings,
and to think about one
another's situations,
which can be really hard in
those sibling conflict moments.
And so looking at how do
we build a relationship so
that they're really
thinking about one another's
feelings inside and outside
these conflict moments?
And it's one of these things
that we scaffold over time,
where we play more of a
role early on, again, trying
to avoid some of the well,
let's just stop the scenario
and get out of this, because I
can't deal with this anymore.
And that will happen sometimes.
Because we'll be too
tired to do anything else.
And that's OK.
But if we can also add in these,
OK, let's talk through this,
scaffolding that so our children
start learning those skills,
so that they can learn
to do that on their own.
DAVID LEVIN: So you
mentioned this a little bit
when we were talking
about bullying, kind
of touching on it somewhat.
But how can we
teach our children
to stand up for
themselves and others
when they're hitting
those types of scenarios?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: It's
a great question.
And I think it's
something that's
starting to get a lot
more attention now
with conversations about how do
we help children be upstanders
rather than bystanders,
or different terms that
are being used.
And one of the ways comes
back to that foundation.
When we show our children
that we are listening to them,
we are taking their feelings
and their words seriously,
they learn that adults
will do that for them.
And not all children
have that in their lives.
And so if repeatedly,
they've been
shown that regardless of
the feelings they've had
or the words they've
shared, no one's listened,
they're probably less likely
to be able to stand up
in those situations.
And so if we've really
built this foundation
to show children that
we take them seriously
and we're here to
listen to them,
they're more likely in those
moments to be able to do that.
But then we also have to
help them prepare for it.
So if you think about
a situation that might
be challenging for a child--
if you're seeing an instance
of bullying for the first time,
or somebody getting
hurt, or somebody
being treated unfairly.
If you've never thought
about that before, but all
of a sudden you see
it, and you think,
oh, that doesn't feel
good, I don't like that.
If we've had those
conversations--
let's say we've read storybooks,
or we've played with dolls,
or role-played
different scenarios
that might be
challenging, or even
talked about different movies
that we've watched together
or TV shows, and talked
about what would you
do in that moment?
We can help our children
learn scripts so they can say.
We can help them learn
and practice saying, hey,
cut that out.
Or help them learn and think
about, well, I don't feel good.
I wouldn't feel good
standing up and saying that.
But I would feel OK going
and telling a teacher,
or going in and asking
an adult for help.
So if we help our children
outside of those moments
think about what they
would do in those moments,
they're more likely
to see it through.
DAVID LEVIN: So we're getting
close to the end of our time,
so I'll ask you some
general questions.
Do you have any other
advice for parents?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Sure.
Let's see.
[LAUGHTER]
A big question.
DAVID LEVIN: Book two!
SHAUNA TOMINEY: A big question.
But I think parenting is hard.
Parenting is hard work.
I think there's a
lot of belief that's
really prevalent
that you should just
know what to do as a parent.
And so when you seek out
support or parenting education,
there's a lot of
stigma that's still
pervasive in our society about
doing that, that that's only
for bad parents, or those
parents who don't know what
they're doing, rather
than acknowledging
that this is learned.
We are trying our
hardest along the way.
And parenting is a challenge,
regardless of your background,
regardless of your
education level.
Parenting some
children is harder than
others, depending on
your own personality,
their personalities,
and their needs as well,
and the context
that you live in.
And so one of the
pieces of advice
I have is to be more
compassionate to one another.
So often, we're
fearful of being judged
when we're standing in
line at the grocery store
and our child is melting down,
or we're in the parking lot,
just trying to get
in the car, and we're
looking around hoping
that nobody else sees us.
And so to think about, what
can we do in those moments
to be a support for one another,
to see each other as learners,
just as we're trying to help
our children see themselves,
and to be there for one another.
DAVID LEVIN: I guess my
last question, and maybe
the last question if nobody else
comes up, but is there anything
else you'd like readers
to know about your book,
"Creating Compassionate
Kids," or in general,
creating compassionate kids?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Sure.
Oh gosh, let me think for a
moment in terms of anything
that we haven't shared yet.
I think that as we said,
it's never too late.
Parenting is hard.
And acknowledging that
the more you know,
the more tools you have
in your parenting toolbox.
And so I really just
appreciate you being here,
appreciate you being
here to learn, to share.
I'd be more than happy
to answer or chat
about specific questions.
DAVID LEVIN: And I don't
get in the last question.
SHAUNA TOMINEY:
Sure, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So I'm probably
going to have white kids.
You talked about
in some situations,
it's more important to--
some families, you end up having
more conversations about what
life is like growing
up, how people
are going to perceive you based
on the color of your skin,
knowing maybe you're going to
have more death in your family
because you're a-- your thing.
What are your recommendations
for having those conversations
from a more privileged
standpoint without instilling
a sense of intrinsic guilt
for having that privilege?
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Yeah.
That is a great question.
And I have a whole section of
the book on, as I mentioned,
self-awareness.
And I think that one
of the things that we
can do for our children is not
just talk about the qualities
that make them who they are.
My daughter is also
very fair-skinned.
She has blue eyes, despite the
other dark eyes in our family.
And she will, in our
country, probably
never be discriminated
against because
of the color of her skin.
And so thinking about how do
we, with children of all races,
talk about race?
And with honesty, in
terms of how challenging
and how race is
seen in our society.
So often, we want
to teach children
that differences don't matter.
But the truth is they do.
There are some children growing
up recognizing and living
the fact that their differences
do matter in the way
that people look at them,
treat them, the opportunities
that they have.
And I think that if
we have conversations
with all of our
children about race,
about sexual orientation,
about gender identity,
about different cultures,
different religions,
we can help our children
think about the impact of that
in their own life,
and help them feel
comfortable emerging into
who they're growing up to be.
But also help them to
see both the challenges
and the strengths that
other people have.
Because we really want them
to see that as a strength,
and that diversity
as a strength,
rather than a difference
to be afraid of.
DAVID LEVIN: And last question.
AUDIENCE: No pressure.
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So we're not
originally from the US.
I'm from Israel, so
we're Jewish, turns out.
And we walk around
with our kids,
and there's these--
you pose with Santa
and all these things.
And you know, my daughter says,
hey, let's stand this line.
And I explain to
her, no, it's OK,
we don't stand in
this line, because we
don't celebrate Christmas.
Why?
Because do Hanukkah, whatever.
The problem happens when
she goes back to school.
And we don't send her
to a Jewish school,
because we feel she
should be with everyone.
Basically, so one of her
friends says something,
like hey, I got picture with
Santa, and my daughter goes,
we don't celebrate Christmas.
[LAUGHTER]
And my instinct is to
try to explain to her,
that's not what you say.
I mean, it's OK for
other people to have--
how do I get around
that while on one hand,
trying to maintain our--
I don't know if its
values or beliefs--
but on the other hand, still
making sure that she respects
everyone else's?
Because she's not
getting a bad example,
but she's perceiving
it that way.
Sorry.
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Yeah.
No, no, it's a great question.
One, all of the other parents
in the classroom, in my opinion,
should be thinking
about how they
talk to their children
about other cultures,
about people celebrating
in other ways,
having other holidays,
other religions.
Because then, when
another child says,
oh, you don't
celebrate Christmas?
What do you celebrate instead?
And seeing that as something
to be interested in,
and wanting to learn about,
and seeing that as part of--
in our community, we
all have different ways
of thinking about things, of
sharing, of coming together
in our family, with our culture.
And so one piece of that
question, which you don't have
control over.
And then the other
in terms of the way
that you approach
your daughter--
it's OK.
And it's OK for her to say,
we don't celebrate Christmas,
here's what we
celebrate instead.
Or here's what's
important in my family.
And I think too
often, it's folks
who, in your case, in
the community that you're
living in, come from
the minority group--
too often, it falls
on your shoulders
to be the one to explain,
to educate, or even
defend your family
to others because
of that lack of
awareness, or the lack
of those conversations.
And that's one of the
things that I really
am striving to help change.
But I think what you're
doing with your daughter--
it's a challenge,
in terms of thinking
about how do we help her then be
that role model of recognizing
where our family fits
in to this other more
dominant society around them.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SHAUNA TOMINEY: Thank
you for bringing that up.
DAVID LEVIN: Thank you very
much for coming and talking
about your book,
and ways that we
can create compassionate kids.
SHAUNA TOMINEY:
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate
you taking the time.
[APPLAUSE]